[Music]
but did Miley Cyrus send Liam Hemsworth
a message in the new Charlie's Angels
song the official music video dropped on
Friday ariana grande Lana Del Rey and
Miley Cyrus in don't call me angel and
the message does seem clear
[Music]
so where does Liam fit into all of this
well he used to call his ex-wife angel
check out the evidence and some fans
have pointed out the guy in the video
kind of resembles Miley's ex it could be
a coincidence but Miley's not shy about
a breakup anthem just last week she
dropped the emotional video for slide
away
[Music]
Miley and Liam announced their split in
August after less than a year of
marriage to be wife husband and wife
it's the best it's the best it's um you
know I feel so lucky to be with someone
like her and yeah it's great very very
very lucky the two tied the knot back in
December but were together on and off
for a decade he's a lot of sushi do and
he actually likes fashion so it's good
that I have a boyfriend that like
dressing they met when she was just 17
on the set of the last song since the
split Miley has seemingly moved on with
Brody Jenner's ex Caitlyn Carter